défi communiste ou communisants vérité
d'hommes semblables limbo
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
maxime fayssac rédacteur chez scopeo et
je vous souhaite à toutes et à tous la
bienvenue sur ce quatrième épisode
et oui déjà le quatrième épisode de
notre série l'entrevue politique
aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux de
recevoir madame caroline janvier député
du loiret jeu sera accompagné pour ce
podcast de la talentueuse 2010 viel
également membre de scopeo à qui je
laisse à présent la parole afin de poser
le décor de ce podcast
et oui merci maxime bonjour à ceux qui
nous écoutent et surtout bonjour à vous
caroline janvier vous nous faites
l'honneur aujourd'hui de nous accorder
cette entrevue pour discuter et débattre
sur un sujet qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur
suite à nos deux tribunes publiées sur
le site scopeo point org le premier
portant sur la db de médecine de
cannabis et puis par maxime pessac et le
second traitant de la légalisation du
cannabis écrit par mes soins nous allons
donc aborder avec vous les thèmes de la
légalisation du cannabis en france et
les modalités de son éventuelle
réalisation
vous êtes bien placé pour en parler
puisque vous êtes la rapporteure de la
partie sur la consommation récréative de
la légalisation du cannabis
mais avant de démarrer lorsque vous
madame caroline janvier je vous laisse
vous présenter bonjour à vous est ravi
d'avoir cet échange aujourd'hui donc
pour me présenter je suis donc député de
la deuxième circonscription du loiret
qui comprend notamment la ville
d'orléans et je sais de commission
affaires sociales et affaires
européennes où je m'investis notamment
sur les questions dans de handicap et
sur un certain nombre de sujets de
société comme le cannabis est donc vous
l'avez rappelé je suis rapporteur de la
partie cannabis à usage récréatif
puisque au sein de cette mission
d'information que nous avons ouverte il
ya maintenant plus d'un an nous avons
souhaité différencier les usages du
cannabis en traitant dans un premier
temps la question du chanvre médical ou
thérapeutique dans un deuxième temps
celui du cannabis à usage bien-être donc
avec du cbd est peu ou pas de thc et
dans un deuxième temps le volet dont je
suis rapporteur thématique le cannabis
10 récréatif ou stupéfiants qui est
finalement le plus connu alors je vais
commencer tout de suite avec notre
première question
nous ce qu'on se demandait à scopeo sait
comment vous en êtes arrivé à cette
position là parce qu'il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui dans le jeu politique et
particulièrement à en marche d'ailleurs
à cette question
c'est pas évident et ça va pas de soi de
se positionner pour une forme de
dépénalisation ou de l'égalisation donc
on a souvent tendance à stéréotypé à
dire oui de toute façon les gens qui
sont pour les légalisation des drogues
ce sont des gens qui consomment des
drogues
donc qu'est-ce que vous en tant que
député vous pouvez nous expliquer
comment vous en êtes arrivé à ce constat
que vous en aurez besoin d'une forme de
légalisation en france sur le ghana
alors je fais partie mois de cette
nouvelle génération d'élus issus d'une
volonté aussi de renouvellement de des
français c'est mon premier mandat d'élu
et ça faisait la question du cannabis
faisait partie des sujets qui m'agace
c'est un peu en tant que citoyenne
puisque il me semblait faire l'objet
d'une forme de tabou voire d'hypocrisie
et d'une forme aussi de de l'acheter
puisque on sait en france depuis 50 ans
on a un des cadres les plus répressifs
sur le sujet avec des peines de prison
et en dépit de cela
ou peut-être même à cause de cela une
consommation parmi les plus importantes
notamment d'europe particulièrement chez
les jeunes
et cette consommation continuent année
après année d'augmenter donc on se
retrouve vraiment dans un paradoxe où on
ne peut que faire ce constat
d'inefficacité de la politique publique
sur ce sujet là donc c'est vrai que
c'était un des sujets sur lequel je me
disais si un jour j'ai des
responsabilités d'élu j'aimerais m'y
atteler et qu'on aborde enfin ce sujet
de façon moins idéologique et plus
pragmatique ne l'a été
merci c'est vrai que il ya énormément de
citoyens qui comme vous et comme nous
peut être agacé par la l'hypocrisie sur
la question ils sont 80% pour la
consultation citoyenne que vous avez
lancé à se prononcer en faveur de la
légalisation du cannabis
pensez vous que cette consultation
citoyenne va être prise au sérieux et
comment l'idée de la légalisation est
elle perçue au sein de l'hémicycle est
enceinte dans marche alors je prends que
cette consultation elle a quand même eu
l'intérêt de montrer qu'au delà d'une
une position très clairement en faveur
d'un changement de législation il y
avait un intérêt pour cette question n'a
plus de 200 quand deux cent cinquante
mille personnes qui auront répondu c'est
la consultation qui arrive en deuxième
parmi l'ensemble des consultations de
l'assemblée nationale en termes de
nombre de réponses donc on voit que
c'est un vrai sujet qui intéresse
l'opinion publique est d'une part et ça
a permis par ailleurs la même façon que
l'ensemble des travaux que nous
conduisons au sein de la mission
d'information de changer un petit peu de
regards et d' approche sur ce sujet là
moi je trouve qu'il ya eu un traitement
médiatique assez intéressant on était
peut-être moins dans la posture et dans
cette approche un peu manichéenne de
dire la drogue c'est mal donc il faut
l'interdire
alors que ce que je défends et on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir c'est de dire
justement parce que c'est un produit qui
peut avoir des effets dangereux
il faut que l'état le réguler comme on
fait pour d'autres substances comme
l'alcool ou du tabac par exemple
donc il ya eu un peu un changement
d'approché je trouve dans le traitement
médiatique et donc cela a généré au sein
notamment de la majorité et du groupe
parlementaire auquel j'appartiens un
certain nombre de débats
est ce que j'ai pu mesurer c'est que
finalement j'ai un certain nombre de
collègues qui sont déjà convaincu par
l'intérêt
de là est la nécessité la légalisation
et j'ai d'autres collègues qui en
réalité ne connaissait une connaît ce
jour pas bien le sujet mais à partir du
moment où ils s'y intéressent et où ils
regardent plus près les chiffres les
comparaisons internationales et bien
finalement ils évoluent sur ce sujet là
donc je crois que vraiment que la
première des priorités c'était vraiment
d'avoir ce débat public et ce changement
d approche sur cette question
en
on s'est pas mal intéressé à vos
interventions dans les médias ou de la
préparation ce podcast et dans un dans
un quotidien qui s'appelle la république
du centre vous parlez en février des des
possibilités sur le long terme d'une
législation et vous parlez quand vous
disait que peut-être en 2022 il pourrait
y avoir un programme qui met qui met
justement en province une proposition
visant la légalisation du cannabis
moi ma question c'est est-ce que vous
pensez que ce programme pourrait être
celui de la république en marche puisque
très récemment on a vu les dernières
sorties du ministre de l'intérieur
gérard grenat qui se positionne très
clairement lui alors qu'il est même dix
membres du même parti coup il se
positionne très clairement contre toute
forme de légalisation je pense même
qu'il utilise le mot de lâcheté pour
qualifier cette législation
alors j'aurai juste apporter plus de
précisions gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur n'est pas membre de la
république en marché un c'est quelqu'un
qui dise tu d'ailleurs des républicains
et qui est donc pour moi il ya une
différence d'une part à établir entre la
politique mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement et les travaux que font les
parlementaires et en l'occurrence les
députés qui donc évalue un certain
nombre de politiques publiques et fond
les propositions et par ailleurs on a
encore un troisième niveau qui est celui
de la préparation d'un projet politique
en 2022 voilà moi évidemment vous poser
une question très clair je voudrais
répondre de façon très claire aussi
ma volonté et j'y travaille de façon
très concrète c'est qu'il y ait un volet
sur la question du cannabis dans le
programme du mouvement politique auquel
j'appartiens donc la république en
marche qu'on aille jusqu'à une
proposition de légalisation avec une
régulation de l'état parce que je
défends où qu'on aille vers la
proposition d'un débat public sur ce
sujet donc il ya différentes
possibilités et je n'ai à ce jour
évidemment aucune garantie puisque je ne
suis pas en charge
comment dire de de rédiger l'ensemble du
projet je vais y apporter ma
contribution
comme d'autres mais c'est évidemment mon
intention est par ailleurs je pense
aussi qu'il est souhaitable et je crois
qu'il est probable que d'autres familles
politiques se positionnent sur ce sujet
là et que ça ne soit plus un sujet
qu'ils soient l'apanage par exemple des
verts ou du ou du ps comme ça longtemps
l'ont été le cas et et vous l'avez vu il
ya eu un certain nombre de prises de
paroles récente je pense à rachida dati
je pense à la tribune de trois maires lr
je pense aux sondages aussi des maires
d'île de france donc il ya un certain
nombre d'évolutions aussi parmi les
responsables politiques
quel que soit leur parti
donc vous pensez que ce mouvement il
pourrait être trans partisan parce qu'on
a vu des gens comme robin reda qui était
chez l air et danièle obono qui a la
france soumise qui eux aussi appelé à
des formes diverses de dépénalisation et
de l'égalisation d'ailleurs dans le
cadre urbain reda c'est assez étonnant
puisque ea c'est le porte parole du
mouvement de la paix casse qui elle-même
se positionne clairement contre
légalisation du cannabis tout cas ce qu
il ya de la haye ce qu'il ya de la
discussion au sein de l'hémicycle entre
les différents entre différents membres
de différents partis politiques
vis-à-vis de cette question du cannabis
bien sûr il ya beaucoup d'échangés de
façon générale il ya beaucoup d'échangés
informels et les choses sur moi comment
dire fermés parfois qu'elles n'y
paraissent après il ya une logique
partisane mais il ya il ya eu linky est
définie et sur lequel les membres d'un
parti doive est évidemment solidaire
mais je crois que ce qui est intéressant
sur le sujet du cannabis c'est que
justement on voit bien que pendant
longtemps il ya eu une approche qui
était celle de l'idéologie parfois de la
posture et finalement ça ça fout c'est
aussi lié à une approche partisane et ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que il ya
un certain nombre d'élus notamment de
deux nouveaux élus qui prennent comme on
dire la responsabilité quelque part de
se défaire de cette grille de lecture
partisane traditionnels pour faire un
certain nombre de propositions donc on
l'a vu en effet avec robert et d'acquis
qui prend une prise opposition assez
courageuse il se trouve qu'on est dans
un contexte là électorale avec notamment
les régionales et valérie pécresse a
précisé notamment à la bien précises hic
au niveau de la région ça n'était pas un
sujet qu'elle allait porter donc elle a
aussi comment dire pas fermé la porte
sur 1 sur d'autres échéances et sur un
an et sur un autre niveau mais en tant
que présidente de région ça naît ça ne
fait pas partie de son projet politique
les essais voilà c'est une forme de
cohérence par rapport à ce canal ce
qu'elle avait par le passé du dit sur le
sujet ça n'empêche pas que robin reda de
continuer à échanger au sein de 2 de sa
famille politique sur ce sujet là et
vous l'avez dit sur les insoumis
effectivement danièle obono
eric coquerel travaille actuellement sur
une proposition de loi sur ce sujet on a
également françois michel lambert du
groupe liberté territoire qui a déposé
une ppl qu'on va examiner le 8 avril en
séance publique sur cette question là
donc en effet c'est vraiment un sujet
trans partisan et je crois que c'est ça
montre aussi le peut-être l'urgence de
mettre en place un changement de
législation sur cette question là tout à
fait et c'est un sujet comme vous l'avez
rappelé sur lequel énormément de dôme et
femmes politiques se positionnent
actuellement
et pourtant pendant beaucoup de temps
les politiques à l'échelle nationale ont
beaucoup éviter ce sujet pourquoi selon
vous est électoralement est-ce que
c'était plutôt le sujet à éviter pour ne
pas effrayer les électeurs
tout à fait vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est un sujet particulièrement sensible
moi quand j'ai commencé à m'y intéresser
j'ai un certain nombre d'élus plus
expérimentés qui m'ont dit de choses qui
m'ont dit d'une part de ne pas aller sur
cette question là parce que c'était un
sujet comme on dire trop connoté et que
je jeu risquait d'apparaître comme
promouvant la consommation cannabis et
comme proposant une forme de
banalisation du cannabis est une part et
d'autre part on m'a dit que de toute
façon même les personnes qui étaient
favorables à la légalisation n'y étaient
pas favorables au point de décider de
leur de leur vote en fonction du
candidat qui propres qu'il ferait cette
proposition
donc en réalité ça n'était de toute
façon pas un sujet suffisamment
important pour remporter des suffrages
et à linverse c'était un sujet voilà
assez assez assez dangereux et qui
risquait de donner une mauvaise image
donc effectivement moi j'étais et je
crois que c'est tout cet aspect un petit
peu tabou tous les fantasmes aussi que
cela génère les confusions entre c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a souhaité à
cette mission d'information bien
différencier les usages et les
substances contenues aussi dans l'eau en
fonction des urgences des des usages que
l'on fait du cannabis parce que il me
semble qu'il ya beaucoup de confusion et
est ce qui freine d'ailleurs sur le
sujet par exemple du cannabis
thérapeutique médicale eh bien la france
a pris du retard elle continue d'en
prendre et aujourd'hui les mêmes
l'expérimentation est rendu complexe par
là un peu la frisonne frilosité de
l'administration par rapport à cela donc
en fait tout ce carcan et 7 et cette
crainte
on fait que l'on n'arrive même pas à
avancer sur un plan par exemple
thérapeutique
alors on est également des élus qui
n'hésite pas à dire que si que la raison
pour laquelle beaucoup d'élus ne se
positionne pas ou ne se prononcent pas
où se prononcent contre
c'est parce que ça sera un moyen
d'acheter la paix sociale dans les
quartiers urbains périurbains qui sont
je pense à des quartiers comme sevran à
certains quartiers de marseille
enfin certains quartiers dans la ville
de sevran pardon qui sont les quartiers
qui vivent entre guillemets de
l'économie du cannabis il y avait
l'ancien maire de sewen n'hésitez pas
qui évoquait les arriérés de loyer qui
étaient parfois avancé en liquide des
arriérés de vingt mille trente mille
euros et que les bailleurs sociaux aller
jusqu'à déplorer les interventions de
police parce que ça voulait dire avoir
du retard sur des loyers qu'elle est
potentiellement être impayés donc à ce
que vous vous pensez que ça expliquerait
le manque d'intervention d'une partie de
la sphère politique cette peur de
déranger une certaine paix sociale comme
certains effets tout à fait on a
longtemps dit est considéré que c'était
une façon effectivement d'acheter
acheter la paix dans born sociale dans
ces territoires là moi je trouve que cet
argument est proprement scandaleux d'une
part parce qu'en réalité quand on creuse
un peu vous avez très peu de personnes
qui vivent de façon confortable du
trafic
on a grosso modo 15 mille personnes qui
gagnent très bien leur vie par rapport à
ça qu'ils sont vraiment les têtes de
réseau trente mille qui la gagnent pas
trop mal et 3 millions qui ont quelque
chose comme 100 euros par jour pour 14 à
16 heures de travail de gay évidemment
sans aucune sécurité d'emploi aucune
aucune cotisation retraite ou maladie
des allers retours en prison enfin avec
tous les risques que l'on connaît et les
dépendances
face à des réseaux et des réseaux
associés de trafic d'armes de
proxénétisme et de et de criminalité
associées donc considérer qu'on offre à
ces jeunes qu'on a rien d'autre à
l'heure à leur offrir que de faire
partie
tout en bas de l'échelle de ces réseaux
criminels qui sont de toute manière
une voie de garage absolue honnêtement
je trouve ça assez choquant et jeu je
trouve courageux un certain nombre
d'élus qui aujourd'hui reconnaissent
qu'en effet ils ont fait pour tout un
tas de raisons pour de la politique
vraiment pour moi de très court terme
mais que mais que c'est un si vous
voulez c'est quelque chose qui en fait
mis en péril des territoires entrée en
entier parce que c'est pas si vous avez
lu le bouquin de bruno laforestrie sur
ce sujet mais en été on à abandonner des
territoires aux mains des dealers et au
moins est aux mains de tous les
criminels qui gravitaient de on a laissé
une mafia se mettre en place d'autres
réseaux associés à cette mafia et on a
dit maintenant courage fuyons pas ce que
parce qu'on a plus les moyens de leurs
noms apparaître conquête républicaine de
tout un tas de choses et donc oui cet
argument je crois que c'est une réalité
malheureusement mais je le trouve
absolument indéfendable
vous avez parlé des des personnes qui
gagnent elles ont l'argent alors qu'ils
vivaient pas forcément très
confortablement verser cet argent mais
qui finançait quand même parfois leur
propre consommation ou leur loyer et
c'est grâce au cannabis comment faire
après une éventuelle légalisation pour
empêcher ces jeunes de se tourner vers
une autre source d'argent facile on
pense notamment aux cambriolages à la
vente d'armes au trafic de drogue d'eau
de drogues dures à la prostitution etc
doivent-ils être spécialement
accompagner pour se réinsérer dans le
marché du travail ou sur le système
scolaire
alors il ya deux choses à mon avis il ya
d'une part essayer de voir si on peut il
ya des certain nombre de pays notamment
des états américains qui travaillent là
dessus les accompagner dans des
démarches et des dispositifs de
reconversion d'une part et d'autre part
parce que ce sont malgré tout des gens
qui en est fait on des expertises sont
des réseaux ont des savoir faire sur ces
sur ces questions là est par ailleurs à
partir du moment où on met en place un
système un marché une filière de
production de distribution légale l'état
peut percevoir un certain nombre de
recettes fiscales qui vont selon les
évaluations de 500 millions d'euros à
2,8 milliards d'euros donc avec des
simples qui sont qui sont importantes et
ça ça permet non seulement de financer
une vraie politique de santé publique
qui aujourd'hui absolument quasiment
inexistante on a tous de 45 millions
d'euros chaque année qui sont dépensés
en prévention ou en soins mais ça permet
aussi de d'investir justement dans ces
quartiers là et d'avoir des vrais
dispositif de formation d'emploi
d'accompagnement de ces jeunes et de
leur offrir justement autre chose que ce
qu'on leur propose depuis depuis 50 ans
on vous seriez favorable par exemple un
système comme au colorado
on propose aux anciens vendeurs
producteurs de cannabis ont été
condamnés pour des faits sans violence
de se reconvertir dans une filière dans
la filière légale parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui se passe au colorado il ya
une vérification du casier judiciaire
est en fait tous les dealers ont été
condamnés mais pas pour des des crimes
avec violence ont leurs propos dans
l'écouté vous n'avez pas fait preuve de
violence donc c'est que je ne vais pas
être foncièrement ou même vous aviez
peut-être pas le choix de faire ça vous
propose de vous reconvertir vous serez
favorable à un système de licence assez
souple comme ça qu'ils viendraient une
véritable voie de reconversion
tout à fait moi je suis favorable je
crois que c'est quand on parle de 3
millions de personnes qui sont
effectivement pas d'échelle de ces
trafics ça fait quand même un certain
nombre de personnes et donc moi je suis
effectivement tout à fait favorable à ce
que l'on accompagne ces personnes et
comment
on voit comment est-ce qu'on peut les
réinsérer quelque part il ya la question
de l'amnistié qui se pose et qui
nécessite à mon avis d'être comment dire
peut-être de faire l'objet d'un débat
public mais qu'est une vraie question
voilà ma part c'est du moment où les
pouvoirs publics considèrent qu'ils se
sont trompés pendant un certain nombre
d'années sur sur la politique publique
qu'ils ont mis en place jusqu'où on va
dans cette reconnaissance d'une quelque
part d'une politique publique non
adaptés mais dans tous les cas en effet
je suis tout à fait favorable à ce qu'on
prenne en compte cette question là et
qu'on avait six de l'argent dans ces
quartiers et auprès de de ces personnes
alors j'aimerais juste revenir sur un
terrain que vous avez utilisé au début
quand vous parliez de l'égalisation
dépénalisation vous dit que ça devait se
faire sous contrôle de l'état sur la
régulation de l'état
moi ma question c'est quel aspect ça
prendrait parce que on pourra reparler
mais il ya des films tant qu ont publié
des rapports où il compare justement les
pays les états où il ya un fort contrôle
de l'état sur le marché et ceux où un
contrôle qui est moindre c'est à dire la
production avait privé la vente elle est
privée ya pas de registre obligatoire
sur lequel s'inscrire les quantités sont
libres il n'y a pas de quotas de
production il n'y a pas trop de taxes
donc le prix pas trop élevé et ils ont
donc je pense en particulier au film
tente de gaspard koenig génération libre
ils ont entre guillemets réussi à
prouver que plus il ya de contrôle de
l'état - le marché noir disparaît parce
que le produit en fait né soit pas assez
disponibles soit trop cher soit les deux
qu'est ce que vous voudrez plus
favorable 1,1 contrôle de ta faim ou
plus un marché libre alors moi je crois
qu'il faut inventer un modèle à la
française
on a deux extrêmes on à l'uruguay on à
la province aussi du du québec où là
vous avez une place très importante de
l'état avec éventuellement un monopole
public et donc un niveau de taxation
prélèvements obligatoires qui est élevé
à un niveau de régulation dans l'octroi
des licences dans d'un contrôle
sanitaire de substances dans d'en
contrôler aussi du des consommateurs qui
sont autorisés à acheter avec une
minorité éventuel mois à 21 ans
donc voilà ça ça permet
d'atteindre un certain nombre
d'objectifs notamment en matière de
santé publique
par exemple la baisse de la consommation
des jeunes le contrôle encore une fois
sanitaire des substances donc ça permet
effectivement de de démontrer aussi que
finalement en reprenant contrôle et bien
la légalisation elle permet finalement
de faire baisser faire baisser la
consommation
il ya un autre aspect que vous avez
cités qui qui tient notamment à la
question plutôt de la sécurité et du
crime organisé
lié au marché noir qui est l'objectif
d'assécher le marché noir et pour ça
vous avez raison il faut que les
consommateurs qui se tournent
actuellement vers le marché noir
trouvent dans l'offre légale une
quantité et une qualité équivalente
c'est à dire qu'effectivement on a vu au
canada les boutiques étaient dévalisés
en quelques heures et donc les
consommateurs ont continué à se tourner
vers le vert le marché noir ou bien le
prix du gramme de cannabis étaient trop
élevées ou bien il n'y avait pas une
variété suffisamment important dans les
produits qui étaient proposées
s'agissant notamment de la teneur en thc
donc donc effectivement il faut il faut
avoir et et dans ces cas là c'est le
rapport gaspard koenig sur ce sujet là
évidemment que le marché aille au moment
où il organise enfin comment dire qu'il
ya une concurrence qui est mise en place
vous avez évidemment plus d'émulation et
plus mais la difficulté quand même de ce
modèle là et là j'en viens à l'autre
extrémité par rapport à l'uruguay ou au
québec que son certain nombre d'états
américains je pense notamment au
colorado où vous pouvez avoir des offres
promotionnelles des incitations à
finalement davantage consommé 2 des
recettes qui vont être utilisés pour
tout un tas de trucs à en couleurs à dos
où je voyais je crois qu'il ya seulement
0 6% des recettes fiscales qui sont
perçus dans le cadre de la vente de
cannabis qui sont affectés à la question
plats santé publique et donc en réalité
la vente de cannabis elle sert à
financer des routes des écoles des
choses comme ça l'un paraît quand même
un peu un peu curieux il faudrait pas
que l'état devienne finalement dépendant
de la vente de cannabis
quel que soit l'âge du consommateur
quand on sait que les moins les moins de
25 ans sont particulièrement vulnérables
à un certain nombre de risques associés
à la consommation de cannabis doit
livrer pas que l'état y est finalement
dans l'intérêt de vendre plus de compte
d'ailleurs recruté comme on l'a fait
avec le débat des consommateurs de plus
en plus jeunes et de leur côté plus
important je crois qu'il ya un équilibre
à trouver
il ya aussi une évolution qui peut être
mis en place c'est à dire une période
transitoire comme ses conseillers
notamment dans le rapport du conseil
d'analysé économique où il conseille de
pendant deux ans d'avoir pour objectif
d'assécher le marché noir avec donc un
niveau de taxe qu'ils soient faibles
après qu'ils soient faibles pour ensuite
augmenter ces éléments là une fois que
le marché noir a quasiment disparu
on peut imaginer un modèle comme ça
évolutif roi mais qu'on se pose la
question de les réguler et de la
régulation de la vente du cannabis donc
quel type de produit est ce qu'on aime
une limite au niveau du thc est ce qu'on
valait beaucoup d'exigences nervo au
niveau de la qualité des produits mais
je voudrais revenir sur elle que vous
avez évoqué la question de l'âge et du
risque que ça pouvait poser pour les
utilisateurs de moins de 25 ans pour les
consommateurs et vous avez évoqué une
éventuelle limitation d'âge à 21 ans
pour vendre du cannabis
est ce que pour vous ce serait vraiment
la meilleure solution de fixer
l'enterrement ou est ce que pour faire
en sorte que les consommateurs qui sont
plus jeunes qui sont adolescents ne
prennent l'habitude plutôt de
s'approvisionner dans le marché légal et
pas dans le marché illégal
il faudrait abaisser ce souffle a par
exemple à 18 ans comment on fait pour
l'alcool
et les deux sens sont envisageables et
encore une fois il faut voir qu'est-ce
qui est le plus efficace si on met une
limite avait un thème un an et qu'en
réalité on a on a un nom de nos jeunes
consommateurs qui continuent de tourner
vers le marché noir parce que et donc on
ne parvient pas à sécher pour cette
raison c'est inefficace
moi je crois que ça sera dans tous les
cas important donc pour moi n'est pas
forcément trancher cette question de 18
ou 21 ans c'est quand même important
c'est d'arriver à dire et comment dire
et il fait de communiquer là dessus sur
le fait qu'effectivement les moins de 25
ans dont le cerveau n'est pas
complètement formés sont beaucoup plus
vulnérables face d'une part au risque de
décompensation psychiatrique avec la
théologie je pense notamment à la
schizophrénie autres est un des troubles
de capacité de concentration de
mémorisation et avec tous les phénomènes
que l'on connaît de décrochage scolaire
et avec des effets qui sont parfois
irréversibles notamment sur ses
capacités de concentration et de
mémorisation
donc ça je crois qu'il faut que ça soit
su que ces jeunes soient mieux
accompagnés qui est davantage de
prévention est ce que l'interdiction
encore une fois et l'élévation de l'âge
à 21 ans sera efficace pas pas forcément
mais en tout cas je crois qu'il faut
qu'on en parle et que dans débat public
c'est c'est une vraie question parce
qu'encore une fois un nu un consommateur
de moins de 25 ans un consommateur de
deux noeuds de plus de 25 ans ne sont
pas du tout face aux mêmes risques
quant à ce canton se produit
moi j'avais une autre question cette
fois ci plus dans le processus de
décision
alors les institutions donc on l'a vu
cette consultation citoyenne de tout de
même 250 mille citoyens qui ont répondu
donc ce n'est pas rien qui a plus de 80
%
l'ebit cité une forme ou une autre de
dépénalisation donc on peut se poser la
question est ce que ça va être pris au
sérieux c'est la question qu'on veut
qu'on vous a opposé début mais est ce
que vous pensez qu'il faudrait aller
plus loin et poser la question sous
forme de référendum aux français
alors je suis toujours partagés sur le
je crois qu effectivement interroger
davantage les français sur un certain
nombre de sujets moi je crois notamment
beaucoup au référendum portait sur des
sujets locaux d'aménagement du
territoire de proximité le danger des
référendums c'est évidemment tout est
d'une part dans la question est celle
approche binaire qui se prête
particulièrement mal au sujet des
drogues et au sujet du cannabis qui
comme je le disais a longtemps pâti
d'une approche manichéenne morale
idéologique sur ce sujet et donc
j'imagine assez bien comment on pourrait
avoir un référendum avec tout un tas de
gens qui seront effectivement de
militants opposés à l'égalisation et qui
ferait peur qu'ils manipuleraient les
données qui donnerait des fausses
informations
et on serait dans un climat moi je crois
que sur ce sujet sensible des drogues il
faut arriver à créer une forme de
consensus c'était le cas au canada au
moment où de six trous d'eau l'a inscrit
à son programme il a mis en oeuvre dans
les deux ans qui ont suivi son élection
mais il y avait je dirais un contexte
politique était favorable et je crois
que c'est un sujet sur lequel on ne peut
pas y aller au forcep on peut pas y
aller en créant un rapport de un rapport
de force parce que parce qu'encore une
fois c'est c'est un sujet trop sensible
donc je ne suis pas joue un débat public
après il faut trouver d'autres formes de
débat public
pourquoi pas encore une fois le
référendum mais il faut il faut que le
contexte s'y prête et qu'on n'ait pas
une ne soit pas une façon de cliver la
société qui je crois n'a pas besoin de
lignes de fracture supplémentaires
justement dans ce processus de décision
on a vu plus en plus de structures
associatives certaines certaines
personnes dire et des cabinets qui
représente certains intérêts cabinet d'
influence pour les structures associées
je pense par exemple à normes et le
france qu'ils plébiscitent justement la
mise en place d'une forme de
légalisation
quelles sont leurs places à ces
associations c'est dans ces commissions
dans ses processus sûr dans ce processus
de décision autour du cannabis c'est ce
qui est ce qu'il arrive à rentrer en
contact avec les élus et ce qu'ils ont
un poids qui est important ou est ce que
pour l'instant on les voit
de loin comme des structures qui font
leurs pulsions internet et on les
rencontre pas vraiment
moi je crois que comme toute association
et groupe
comment dire militants ils ont
évidemment un intérêt et une parole qui
doit être prise en compte dans le débat
public nous avons eu l'occasion d
auditionner moi je suis régulièrement
interpellé notamment sur twitter par un
certain nombre de ces de ces
associations qui sont comment dire par
définition militante sur le sujet moi je
crois que l'intérêt principal au delà de
la question militante
c'est le l'expertisé et je trouve assez
utile d'avoir et après tout dépend de la
façon dont se positionne quand on se
positionne en tant que comment dire aux
militants de façon je dirais trop
dogmatique ou excessives
à mon avis ça n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt
et d'ailleurs on le voit dans les
réseaux sociaux en fait la possibilité
de débat elle est en réalité très
limitée et plus on a une approche qui et
je dirai fermé et radicale et +7 7
cet espace il est diminué en revanche le
moi je le voyais notamment sur twitter
j'avais un certain nombre de de ses
comptes twitter qui par exemple cette
intervention que je faisais eh bien
venez à mener de l' expertise et donc
moi j'ai le je lisais vous citez normale
et j'ai eu un certain nombre de
documents qui portait notamment à votre
connaissance sur twitter qui est ça je
trouve ça tout à fait utile et là on est
dans l'échangé de connaissances si on
est dans le oui le partage de
connaissances et je trouve ça tout à
fait intéressant donc moi l'intérêt je
le vois je le vois beaucoup la plus que
dans la confrontation parce qu'encore
une fois sur ce sujet là il me semble
qu'il ya beaucoup de méconnaissance et
de confusion et donc on a tout intérêt à
faire preuve de pédagogie et de et des
coudes sereine
voilà des des avis des peurs des
fantasmes éventuellement de chacun pour
avancer pour avancer sur ce sujet
vrai que c'est un sujet dont on parle
aussi beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
et un certain manque de bouc qui seront
attribués les temps en faveur de la
légalisation
on peut considérer que c'est plutôt les
jeunes qui sont concernés par cet idiot
globaux puisqu'ils sont davantage sur
les réseaux sociaux
est ce que vous constatez une grande
évolution de l'opinion publique ou alors
la fracture générationnelle sur cette
question là alors oui c'est amusant
parce que à la fois j'ai le sentiment
que chez les jeunes est vraiment la
nouvelle génération c'est presque has
been le sujet du cannabis
d'ailleurs je voyais je crois c'est la
fdt aussi qui faisait remarquer à raison
que si la consommation continue
d'augmenter d'année année après année
elle diminué c'est très récent et c'est
une bonne nouvelle chez les jeunes elle
commence tout juste à diminuer chez les
jeunes moi j'ai le sentiment que les
jeunes finalement consomme sans doute un
peu moins de cannabis et quand ils
consomment des substances psychoactives
y vont se tourner vers d'autres drogues
des drogues de synthèse et et et et
autres donc moi j'ai jamais qui vous dit
franchement le cannabis est vraiment pu
tourner au dessus mais en revanche là où
il ya peut-être un effet générationnel
c'est encore une fois sur cette approche
est sur cette grille de lecture un petit
peu idéologique en tout cas chez les
représentants de la classe politique est
aussi dans un certain nombre de médias
qui on avait d'un côté les libertaires
qui disait de façon décomplexée que
effectivement c'était un produit tout à
fait inoffensif et de l'autre les par
les partisans d'une approche très fondée
sur l'ordre et la morale qui disait que
c'était très très grave en faisant un
amalgame de cannabis avec l'héroïne avec
la cocaïne avec avec tout ça j'ai
l'impression que le peut-être le
changement générationnel il permet de
changer d'appproche en revanche j'ai le
sentiment que c'est peut-être un peu
moins un sujet chez les jeunes
générations que gelée que chez les gens
peut-être par exemple de ma génération
et alors est ce que cette fracture
générationnelle vous la sentez aussi du
côté des députés
vous parliez tout à l'heure des gens qui
est des fois
sont personnellement pour une fin de
l'égalisation mais qui ne veulent pas se
supporter mais après il ya peut-être
aussi sincèrement des gens qui quand on
se met à parler de l'égalisation des
armées vous êtes vous vous êtes folle
c'est la porte ouverte à toutes sortes à
toutes sortes de choses dont je me dis
logiquement lui c'est peut-être des gens
qui sont en politique depuis plus
longtemps c'est peut-être des gens qui
sont plus âgés
est-ce que vos à l'hémicycle vous avez
senti c'est pas une certaine forme de
jugement une partie des meetings
vis-à-vis de vos positions
peut-être même des fois des gens qui
essaient de vous discréditer en faisant
assez c'est celle qui veut du cannabis
ou des choses comme ça oui moi on est
une femme moi j'ai souvent des retours
et ça je le regrette pour le coup de
gens ne prennent pas ce sujet au sérieux
qui vont caricaturer qui vont faire des
pipes lagon 21 juin en en en faisant
quelque part un sujet comment dire
presque de niche et un petit peu et un
petit peu caricatural sans voir toutes
les dimensions que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure de l'aménagement du territoire
de d'équité aussi comme on dit entre
entre les territoires de justice sociale
aussi parce que typiquement le cannabis
on sait bien que les consommateurs ne
sont pas traités de la même façon en
fonction du lieu où vous habitez dans
l'est dans les beaux quartiers quand les
constructeurs se font livrer soit par
des livreurs soi même carrément par la
poste
en commandant sur internet ne se passe
jamais rien pour eux et ils n'ont pas à
subir les conséquences des deals au bas
de leur immeuble
ok il ya beaucoup d'aspects finalement
dans cette question et je trouve que le
réduire de façon un petit peu ironique à
quelque chose un sujet
voilà comment dire encore une fois
libertaire et un peu et un peu datés et
associés aux années 68 et suivantes
c'est un peu dommage et c'est un peu oui
c'est une forme de comment dire de
renoncement finalement encore une fois
mais qui s'inscrit dans une dans une
histoire longue un finalement puisque la
france est depuis cinquante ans dans
cette situation on a entendu pendant
cinquante ans cette question là et je
crois que notamment pour un certain
nombre d'élus qui ont qui était présent
lors des débats sur ces questions là
reconnaître que pendant cinquante ans on
s'est trompé dans la proche
c'est un peu compliqué c'est un peu
compliqué j'entendais un élu à la région
ile de france qui parlait de défaite
morale et je crois que si on prend les
choses comme ça en effet je ne recule
jamais et on continue les mêmes erreurs
pour ne pas avoir à dire que c'était que
c'était une erreur donc pour ça je ne
pense qu'un effectivement le changement
quelque part générationnel et quelque
part peut-être utile pour pour pas avoir
à faire ce travail là
il est très regrettable d'entendre que
certains considèrent que c'est un débat
qui pourrait être ne pas être pris au
sérieux voire qui pourrait être un sujet
de niche et pourtant c'est un débat qui
est directement reliée aux questions
d'insécurité notamment dans des
quartiers sensibles
or on a vu dans le dernier opinion way
que l'insécurité était la première
préoccupation des franciliens la proche
des régionales comment est ce que vous
voyez les deux sujets et d'après vous
quelle quelle est la corrélation entre
l'insécurité et le trafic de cannabis et
donc quelles seraient les solutions
qu'elle serait vraiment les conséquences
concrètes au niveau de l'insécurité
grâce à la légalisation du cannabis
bon alors moi je crois qu'en effet vous
avez raison les deux sujets sont
extrêmement liés et est quelqu'un voilà
quand bruno laforestrie que je citais
tout à leur montre bien les différents
réseaux les différents niveaux de
criminalité qui sont associées au trafic
de cannabis qui est quelque part un
trafic très accessible très fatigué qui
est souvent la première porte d'entrée
vers d'autres d'autres réseaux et vers
d'autres trafics donc donc très
clairement ça serait à mon avis une
façon tout à fait pertinente si elle est
travaillé suffisamment en amont avec
notamment la structuration
l'organisation d'une filière légal qui
permette d'absorber en qualité et en
quantité
les demandes des consommateurs actuels
je crois que on aurait effectivement une
un certain nombre de problématiques et
de trouble à l'ordre public qui sont
aujourd'hui associés qui diminuerait de
la même façon que ça permettrait de
libérer le million d'heures on avait vu
ce chiffre
le million d'heures annuelles qui est
aujourd'hui utilisée pour lutter contre
contre les trafics par les forces de
l'ordre
cela coûte 570,8 millions d'euros par an
et représente donc un million d'heures
et donc tout ce temps là qui est pris
pour quelque part lutte est un phénomène
qui ne fait que grandir et contre lequel
on est dans une forme d'impasse eh bien
ça serait autant de temps qu'ils
pouvaient être consacré à d'autres
missions pour nos forces de l'ordre à un
rétablissement d'une d'un maintien de
l'ordre de proximité à plus de relation
de confiance dans ces quartiers et on
sortirait au petit peu aussi de cette
situation complètement ubuesque où
finalement la france à une doctrine à un
cadre en théorique parmi les plus
répressifs mais c'est un cadre qu'il
n'est pas appliquée puisqu'elle n'a pas
les moyens de sa mise en oeuvre
quand on considère qu'on à 900 milles
consommateurs quotidiens il faudrait à
peu près 330 millions interpellation par
an pour sanctionner c'est ce ne serait
ce que c'est que ces consommateurs
quotidiens donc on ira une situation où
on donne une feuille de route une
mission à nos forces de l'ordre et elles
ne sont pas en mesure de le mettre en
oeuvre donc on les met dans une
situation d'échec perpétuel ou dans
certains cas ils préfèrent fermer les
yeux et le disent parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens et qu' ils
retrouveront le lendemain le
surlendemain les mêmes personnes
ou quand il démantèle des réseaux et
bien d'autres les remplacent dans les 24
heures dans certains cas ils ferment les
yeux et dans d'autres ils s'épuisent et
perdent finalement en crédibilité
puisque les personnes qui le qu'ils
poursuivent on voit bien qu'il ne ne
sont pas en capacité d'aller au bout
donc je crois que ça serait en effet
tout à fait une réponse pertinente ça ne
résoudra pas tous les problèmes il
faudra penser à c'est parce que l'on
évoquait en terme de réinsertion
il faudra voir comment on investit aussi
de l'argent dans ces territoires
mais je crois que ça serait une première
étape en effet pour répondre aussi à
cette question de la sécurité justement
pour essayer de pallier ce problème
d'une énorme quantité de consommateurs
et donc de personnes qui commettent des
délits
tous les jours on a vu donc la dernière
gérald darmanin qui a proposé cette
solution de l'amendé forfaitaire donc
qui permettait de désengorger et les
tribunaux et donc d'aller beaucoup plus
vite dans dans la sanction pénale
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
amende forfaitaire et à quel point pour
vous est-ce qu'elle résout en partie ce
problème là avant le forfait pays qu
elle est d elle n'a qu'un intérêt à mon
avis elle permet aux forces de l'ordre
d'avoir une réponse rapide immédiate et
réelle
un phénomène coquelles ils sont
confrontés et qui c est qui et qui
parfois les comment dire les met dans
une situation où en effet ils se sentent
illégitime inefficace puisqu'il revoit
la même personne lendemain au même
endroit
donc ça se mérite là mais ça n'est
qu'une seule réponse à une toute petite
partie du phénomène et notamment à la
question très concrète du trouble à
l'ordre public
ça n'est ni une réponse au trafic
évidemment ça n'est pas une réponse non
plus à la consommation et notamment sa
introduit une forme de discrimination
entre les consommateurs puisque encore
une fois les personnes qui habitent dans
les quartiers bourgeois qui se font
livrer ne se font jamais ennuyé et ne
font jamais l'objet de d'amendés
forfaitaires délictuelle donc encore une
fois on va pénaliser plus tôt les
personnes qui ont les plus faibles
revenus et qui vivent dans des
territoires qui sont déjà comment dire
mis en difficulté et avec des problèmes
d'insécurité est par ailleurs ça enlève
finalement la possibilité d'un
accompagnement dans un dans un soin
notamment des usagers qui ont une
consommation problématique puisque nous
n'avons plus la jonction de soins qui
était pour le coup dans un cadre pénal à
partir du moment où le consommateur
était et est donc pour moi c'est
vraiment une réponse très ponctuel très
limité très limitative et qui est encore
une fois presque un aveu d'échec et
d'impuissance chez moi ce que j'aimerais
rajouter c'est que ce qui est dommage
c'est qu'il ya aucun débat sur le
bien-fondé en soi de la question de la
langue se dire que maintenant c'est
automatique
et on est consommateur on est forcément
un trouble à l'ordre public et on nous
donne une langue alors que le débat
devrait être sur le fond de vraiment
même pour les gens qui n'aiment pas le
cannabis qui ne veulent pas en consommer
en quoi quelqu'un qui a consommé qu'ils
consomment
il ya quelques ann curry est un trouble
à l'ordre public et ça c'est une vraie
question qui malheureusement est trop
souvent ignorée par contre j'aurai une
autre question sur la police donc
intéressant avec la police c'est que à
la fois on a des groupes comme police
contre la prohibition qui vont mettre en
avant des arguments pour dire ben non on
n'en peut plus d'arrêté des comptes
demande d'arrêter des gamins juste parce
qu'ils ont une boulette de shit sur eux
on veut on veut faire notre travail de
flics on veut
on veut protéger la paix et l'ordre mais
de l'autre côté on a aussi des policiers
qui très clairement se positionne contre
eux disent que oui il faut absolument
continuer de combattre ça et donc en
face on a des gens qui n'hésitent pas à
dire que s'il ya des flics qui entre
guillemets voit d'un bon oeil que la
légalisation continue c'est parce qu'il
ya aussi de la corruption dans la police
et ça il n'y a pas besoin de le montrer
par a plus b tous les ans il ya des
affaires sortent ces quelques années
c'est y avait une grosse grosse affaire
de corruption au sein des stups à à
paris est-ce que vous pensez que voilà
c'est une question un peu tabou mais
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
corruption que ce soit dans la police
mais aussi dans une partie de la classe
politique parce qu'il faut pas se
leurrer il ya des livres qui sont aussi
sortis là dessus de dealers qui le dit
très clairement qu'il ya des politiques
qui touchent l'argent de la drogue
est-ce que vous pensez que ça a un
impact dans ce texte est une des cause
de la lenteur de cette question de la
légalisation qui peine arrivé de
question de la corruption
c'est une question qui est compliqué
parce que pour y répondre il faudrait
connaître la réalité et l'ampleur du
phénomène et ça évidemment on ne le sait
pas on a quelques voilà quelques
scandales et quelques affaires qui nous
permettent et donc de dire que c'est une
réalité
quel point cette réalité est importante
et à quel point elle a un impact sur les
prises de positions et les uns les
autres
honnêtement je serais bien incapable de
vous le dire et je voudrais pas tomber
non plus dans une approche un petit peu
comment dire peu facile de considérer qu
en réalité si on n'a rien fait sur ce
sujet là depuis 50 ans parti c'est parce
qu'en réalité tout le monde est mouillé
et que et que voilà donc pour avoir
discuté par exemple localement notamment
avec des gendarmes sur ce sujet aussi
des policiers des gendarmes notamment en
milieu rural il était tout à fait
convaincu de la nécessité de continuer
avec cette approche prohibitives pour
tout un tas de raisons que je que je
n'ai pas à juger que et que d'ailleurs
je respecte et comment dirais je
je peux tout à fait attester de l'assad
de leur sincérité du fait que
[Musique]
semblait pas kaki et d'autres raisons
dans leur raisonnement
donc ça explique peut-être voilà pour
une petite partie un certain nombre de
prises de position moi ce que m'ont
aussi dit beaucoup de syndicats ou de
personnes dessus des forces de l'ordre
police ou gendarmerie
c'est qu'en réalité leur mission c'est
de respecter la feuille de route qu'il
aurait donné et à partir du moment où on
leur donne cette mission-là le dire ils
vont effectivement mettre tout en oeuvre
pour l'amener le mieux possible et si
les orient et après il s'agit d'un choix
politique dont on sait les orientations
politiques changent et que et que voilà
et qui est un bien fondé à ceux à ce
changement et bien ils seront ils seront
dans une situation quoi donc je ne crois
pas que ça soit le point de blocage
majoritaire je dirais bien et bien pour
ma part vous avez répondu à toutes mes
questions vous remercie pour le temps
que vous avez pris pour nous répond je
pense que domitille également vos merci
merci beaucoup à la merci beaucoup pour
tout vos réponses qu'on était très
informative et très intéressante
donc je pense que ça va être là la fin
de ce podcast qui nous tenait vraiment à
coeur et qui peuvent vraiment sur un
sujet qui à mon sens au sens de maxime
aussi n'est absolument pas un sujet de
nice qui est un sujet à ne pas prendre
au sérieux puisqu'il touche à la fois à
la finance à la santé publique à
l'insécurité donc énormément de sujets
qui sont très importants pour le
bien-être des français donc on vous
remercie encore une fois d'avoir pris ce
temps et de nous avoir donné cette
attention et je souhaite à soit bientôt
sur sur scopeo et je vous souhaite à
vous une bonne 30 jours mais et ben
merci à vous également et est ravie de
cet échange